よろしくお願いします
今日から五回に分けて心というテーマ中心に釈尊の考え方を紹介したいと思っております
で 前回もまた五回のなんて言いますか
講座がありましたけど
それは釈尊の生涯のことでしたし
その時はこのある方にこのもう肝心な釈尊の教えはどこですかと聞かれて聞かれたんですね
それは私もそれはそうなんですねと答えたんだけども
釈尊の生涯のことを説明しましたけど
なかなか何をおっしゃったんですかということは言わなかったんですね
で 今度の五回の講座では
釈尊おっしゃった教えのほんの微かな一部だけ皆様に紹介したいと思っています
で 内容は大変理解しにくくて難しいんです
ですから このあまりこの深いところに入らないで
この我々に分かりやすい
現代的な我々考えているところに当てはめるところだけ選んで話しようと考えているんです
で 仏教の知識なんか前もってなくても構いません
かえっていろんな知識なかった方が無い方が純粋に理解できると思います
で 一つ最初から申し上げたのは
このお釈迦様の教えっていうのは
このある人々に何か特定
特色な 特別な宗教を徹底的に強引に押し付ける教えではないんです
それをよく理解してほしいんです
釈尊のこの元々の純正の教えっていうのは
不可思議に現代的なんです
現代の誰かが自分が発見した何か知恵をみんなに広報して発表する
それは人々は自分で理解して納得いけばよろしいし
納得いかなければそれで構いませんとという立場で教えた教えなんです
どんどん時代経ってくると
なんかすごい堅苦しい宗教の形に嵌めてしまったんですね
それをもう世の中でいろいろ宗教がありますし
この哲学っていうのは宗教の世界が守ってきたものだから
やっぱりそうなってしまったんです
そこで世の中に宗教のあるこのいろいろしきたりやら厳しいところやら
いろんなものも入ってしまっちゃって
宗教になってしまったんだけど
もともとは宗教のようなものではなくて
どなたにでも自由に考えて
それから反論して それからいろいろ質問して
ディスカッションして理解できるように教えた知識の知恵の教えなんです
ですから 釈尊が私言うことは信じなさいという言葉は全くないんです
信じなさいと いつでも言うのは
あなた方は自分で考えてみなさいということ
それから まあそれで我々も私が言うことは
できるだけ釈尊がおっしゃったことは
その通りには皆様に日本語で言うことはちょっと無理ですけど
なぜならば解釈つけなくちゃいけないし
そのまま言うと分からなくなりますから
まあいくらか私の解釈入りますけど
で 私が言うことを皆様方は自分で考えて
理解して 反論して もう戦ってみて
抗議してみて 考えてください
とても自由なんです で
人が束縛するのは仏教はもう大変良くないと思っているんです
ですから この人の話聞いて
それに圧倒されて すぐそのまま信じ込んじゃうんです
それは人間の性格なんです
この先入観という恐ろしいものがありまして
それからマインドコントロールという言葉
日本語でよく使っている言葉で
すぐコントロールされやすいんですね
人間というのは それから物事を自分で理解するよりは
まあ信じた方が手っ取り早くて便利で安全
便利ではないかというふうに思っているんですね
その心の弱みを使って我々は現代生きてるんですね
例えばこのいろんなこの宣伝広告ございますね
いろんな商品の そういうのは完全に人の心の弱みを握って使っている
作っているものなんですね
これ一つさえあればもう全部OKですよと
なんかすごい品物のように宣伝したりする
それに宣伝する人々も大変かっこよくて
人気のある人々が出てきて説明する
そうすると その雰囲気に圧倒されて
我々は品物を買ってしまっちゃうというふうな
この心の弱みがあるんですね
で 仏教はなんで人間理解しないかというと
この心 そもそも本来持っているその弱みをなんとかもうなくしてしまおうと
人々は自立させてしまったらどうですかと
独立させたらどうですかと
人々に自分で自分のことを判断できるような
もう力強いものをしちゃったらどうですかという
世界で誰もやらないことをやろうとしているんですね
ですから 仏教はいつでもすごい
なんて言いますか 特別な教えになっているんです
仏教といっても この釈迦尊の教えは
[咳]ですから なかなか広げないんですね
広げても一代で終わってしまっちゃって
二代目からもう自分なりの教えになってしまっちゃうんですね
それはどういうことかというと
やっぱり世の中っていうのは
あの 偉大なる人を信仰して
その人言うことはそのまま信じて
それに従って生活したいんですね
誰か救い主というんですか
この救済者みたいな人が現れてきて
その人の偉大なるパワーで
偉大なる力で 我々の希望通り何でもやってくれるならば
ありがたくていいんじゃないかという
我々の本来心の中にそういう状態がございます
で 今の皆様 自分の心に聞いてみてください
正直に もし誰かが人間でもいいし
人間でない存在でもいいし
偉大なるパワーを持っている
限りのないパワーが持っている人がいて
私はあなたの希望通り何でもやってあげるんですよと思ったならば
どれほど自分たちが喜びますかと
私たちは弱い心を持っているんです
そこで世の中のすべての経済学も宗教も哲学も
他の文学系統の教えも
芸術も その概念にもそれを使って
その土台の上に成り立っているんです
いわゆる我々の弱みを握っているんです
芸術家もそうなんですね
素晴らしい そういう才能ある人々が来て
自分の才能を見せて 我々を圧倒して
まあそれで終わりと 例えば我々が本を一冊買うことにしたっても
さっさとその あの 本をお書きになった人がどんな経歴の人か
どんな大学出ているんですかと見て
それに本を買ってしまっちゃうんですね
アメリカの大学を卒業しているんだ
イギリスの大学を卒業しているんですかとか
あるいは日本では東大
京大 早稲田とか そういう何とかの有名な大学を卒業しているんだとか聞いたところで
まあすぐ信じてしまっちゃうと
で かすかにでも いくらハーバードを卒業したっても
もしかするとおかしい人ではないかというふうな疑問は持たないんですね
何とか何とか大学出ているんだから
やっぱり素晴らしい人やと
まあそこの信仰を持ってまあ帰ってしまうんですね
ですから そういう性格がある
で 釈尊だけは それを破ってしまったらどうですかと
という立場で教えてるんです
ですから まあちょっと人間がなんか好きじゃない性格はあるんです
好きにならない性格があるんです
ある日こういう対話があったんです
で ある修行者がもう大変修行していろんな修行して
心ということを 自分の魂をなんとか清らかにしようと一生懸命一生をかけて頑張ってきて
もう疲れちゃったんです
素晴らしい心優しい優れていた優れていた人でしたけど
結局疲れちゃったんです
ありとあらゆる方法を試したところで疲れちゃって
まあ釈尊という悟った人がいるんだという話を聞いて
釈尊に会うんですね それだったらその人に会ってみましょうと
で 話は大変広くてあって
釈尊はもう完全に悟っているんだと
他の行者がみんな頑張ってはいるんだけど
この完全たる悟りの境地はまだまだ見つかってなかったんだと
それで釈尊は道を見つけただけではなくて
今はみんなに教えているんだと
その道をたどって もう悟っている人は大勢いるんだと言われたところで
その情報に惹かれて じゃあそれだったら私も指導を受けてもらおうと思って
そのお釈迦様はその人に
お釈迦様にその人が会うんですね
会ったところで その人こう聞くんですね
で 私はいろんなこの心の問題について
いろいろ探し求めていて
もうもう疲れてるんだと
ですからお願いしますから
私を救ってくださいと
お釈迦様の言葉はナハンガミッサーミパモーチェナーヤ
カタンカティサットサッバローケ
お釈迦様の言葉はものすごい逆なんですね
あれほど私はいろんなありとあらゆる問題で悩んでいて
もうもうどうにもわからない状態になっているんだと
ですから助けてください
救ってくださいと言ったところでお釈迦様の答えは
いえ 私はそういうありとあらゆる悩みに
もう悩みに悩んで もうどうしようもない人々なんかはね
救ってあげませんと 私は人を救うものじゃないんだと
救い者ではないんだと
いきなり言うんです それはやっぱり普通の宗教の人は言わない言葉なんですよ
例えば人が私たちでも
例えば悩みがあってカウンセリングを受ける
そこでカウンセラーのところにも一応予約して
電話して 時間を決めて
せっかく会ったところで
いきなりあなたは助けてあげることは全然できませんと言っちゃったら
どうなるんですかね そうすると商売はならない
成り立たないというふうな
ごくちょっと良くない言葉なんですけど
そうするともう仕事にならなくなっちゃうんですね
そうじゃなくて 我々が考えているのは
ああそう よく来ていただきました
いらっしゃいませと ああ
もう何とかしてあげましょうと
そういうふうに慰めの言葉なんですね
必要なのは 大丈夫です
大丈夫です もう心配すること何もない
もうこちらに来たんだから
もうもう安全だと 大勢の人々はこちらに来るんだと
なんとかなんとか人も来ましたと
なんとかタレントさんも来ましたと
なんとか有名な人も来ましたと
なんとかの政治家も来ましたと言って
写真ダラーッと並んで
それでサイン入り いろいろあったりして
すると ああ やっぱりこの人はすごいんだと
助けてくれるんだ 救ってくれるんだというのは我々のごく普通な考え方なんです
ですから お釈迦様の道というのはすごい大胆といえば大胆なんです
いきなりこの悩みに悩んでいるこの人に
いえ 全然救ってあげませんと言ったんです
で そこに本当のところ
そこに真実があるんです
救ってあげませんよと言ったところに
そこに本物があるんです
そこがポイントなんです
なんでそんなに大胆なことを
自分 何て言いますか 自己破壊と言うんですか
自分で自分の首を自分で絞めるようなことを言うんですかと
お釈迦様はみんなに伝道して歩き回っていたんだから
私は誰一人助けられませんと言いながら説法できないでしょうに
助けてあげませんよ 救ってあげませんよというところに何かあるんです
だからインドの人々はお釈迦様に会って
法を聞いて 悟り 解脱を体験したんです
そこでその人にお釈迦様が言うのは自分で見なさい
自分のこと 自分で理解しなさい
自分でやってみなさい
一応方法だけを教えてあげますと
ですから お釈迦様っていうのは
私は道を教えますと で
あなたはやってみてくださいと
そういうことなんですね
ですから 例えばまあこちらは知識の方々で
別に宗教の話聞こうと
この話を聞いて なんとか体の病気でも
この人もこの坊主の力で治してもらおうというふうな考え方で来ていらっしゃる方々一人もいませんと思いますけど
ですから この釈尊の場合もやっぱり同じことで
この道を教えてあげる
我々はそれを実践してみる
体験してみる 試してみる
この救ってもらいたいというのは
このまずそこをちょっと考えてみましょう
この偉い人に従って 偉い人にも完全に自分を
この何と言いますか 無条件に身を投げて差し上げちゃって
もう何でもいいんだからやってくださいという場合は
まず一つは 我々はものすごい無気力でであることなんですね
一つ 二番目は 我々はものすごい怠け者なんですね
やってもらいたがってるんですね
人に その二つもあまり良くないでしょ
怠け心も良くない それから無気力状態も良くないんですね
ですから 我々は心に巨大な毒
猛毒二つ二種類持っていて
それを守りながら解毒してくださいと
解毒というんですか 毒をなくしてちょうだいと
というと矛盾なんです
救われません そこで仏教の立場っていうのは事実を見ましょうと
データ FACTS じゃあ世の中でこの偉大なる誰かに救ってもらって
完全に心清らかにした人が一人もいますかと
と聞いたっても なかなか皆様は答えられませんと思いますけど
で 私は大胆に答えますけど
一人もいないと言いたいんですね
なぜならば この人でもいいし
何か偉大なる存在でもいいし
そのものにすがっていると
永遠に我々はもう束縛された状態で
自由になるくはないんです
我々の弱い状態はずっとそのままなんです
無気力の状態 それから怠け状態
そのままなんです いわゆる操れるだけなんです
どうぞ私を自由自在に操ってくださいという人が
いつか自由になるということはないんですね
操ってもらうためには
自分が自分の意思を全部捨てなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから 自由にならないんです
問題は解決しないんだと
そこをちょっとまあ なんかちょっとわかりにくいかもしれませんだけど
これは全部この話に入る前の話なんです
いわゆる条件ですね で
仏教で次に考えてほしい特色っていうのは
この証拠ないものはほとんど語らない
いわゆる証拠ないものは語っても何も意味がないんだと
それどういう意味ですかね
例えばこの浅井会長のそういう精神的なことに対する考察にしたっても
このいわゆる精神の世界のことを知りたがってくるんですね
そこでよくあることっていうのは
この科学のことは我々はよく知ってるんだと
それは科学っていうのはちゃんと証拠があって
それなりの世界は科学であって
証拠ないものは語るのは精神的な世界だと
と すごいこの誤解があるんです
その誤解は いわゆる弱さがありますね
その弱さがものすごく上手にすごい人々が使っているんです
使っていきなりこういう話始まるんですね
人間の魂はと話しちゃうんですね
話はすぐ人間の魂はというふうに話始まる
あるいは我々の尊い魂はとか
あるいは我々の永遠不滅の魂はとか
そういうふうに始まっちゃうと
いきなり我々はそうですかということで話を聞く
それで言うことを何でも信じる
信じざるを得ない状態になってしまっちゃうんですね
あるいは神様はと始まります
神様は偉大なる人であると
いきなり信じてしまっちゃうんですね
そこで仏教は この精神世界にしたっても
やっぱり証拠ないものは置いておけと
例えば魂はと言った途端
魂って何？という質問はしないんですね
まず魂がある それを証拠を出してくださいと
それに証拠を出してくれなきゃ
魂にすべていくらかかって語っても
それはもう無駄話なんですね
捨ててくださいと よくこの俗世間である話
こういう話あるんで 人は死んでも霊魂
魂は死ぬわけじゃないんだと
そういう信じる人々がいるんですね
じゃあ証拠を出してくださいと言ったら
証拠一つも出せないんですね
例えばもう田中さんが死んだんだけど
田中さんの霊魂が ほら
ご覧なさい こうまだ生き続けているんではないかと
そういう例は 証拠は誰も出してくれないんですね
ですから このまた仏教は大胆なんですね
証拠は出せっこはないものは扱わない
証拠は必要ないというならば
どんなくだらないことでも喋られるんです
例えば 私は人間の角について喋る
つのあの この牛とかね
あの鹿とか持ってますね
そこで私は人間の角について喋る
もしいきなり今日は人間の角について講演ですよと
人間の角というのはという話始めちゃったら
皆様も聞いていただけるならば
もう何でも喋られるんですね
角の長さ 色 こういうもので出来上がっているんだとか
それはこういうこういうことに使えるんですかとかですよとか
何でも喋れるんですよ
でも まず必要なのは人間に角があるかないかということなんです
そこで僕はいえいえ そんな証拠は要りませんよ
まず信じなさいと言っちゃったら
角は銀色でできているんだと
心清らかな人の角は銀金ですよと
心はほぼ綺麗な人の角は銀ですよと言っても
そうですか じゃあ私も金の角が欲しいやと
だからどうすればそれ得られますか？とみんな頑張るかもしれません
でもくだらないんですね
そういう話っていうのは
僕はこのわざわざと馬鹿げた例を出しちゃったんです
なぜならば 人間に角はないということを我々はまあまあ知っていることだから
同じことなんですね この魂はとか霊魂はとか神様はとかね
というふうに話し始めると同じことなんです
そこで 仏教と他の世界にある考え方の違うところ
特に精神世界の考え方の違うところは
やっぱり仏教は精神のことにしたっても
証拠に基づいて証拠に基づいて喋るんです
そこ大変必要なものなんです
いわゆる実験やら それから試すこと
正しいかないかとか 試したりしてみるのは
まあ釈尊の教えの特色なんですね
それ 仏教は宗教になったところで
それ切れちゃったんです
例えば もう仏様というのはありがたいものやとか
阿弥陀様は我々を救ってくれるんだと
そういうふうな話になっちゃったんです
人間が亡くなって ちゃんと法事をやってあげれば成仏できますよとか
でもそういうのはもともと釈尊の教えではなかった話なんですね
他の宗教からもう入り込んだものなんです
ですから 仏教というのはものすごい科学性を持ってるんです
ですから 仏教というのはあくまでもこのインテリの人々のためであって
知識人のためであって
まず聞く場合はそうでない人々も聞くとどんどん元気になって
ものすごいもう力強い
もう独立した人々になってしまっちゃうんですね
で 頭が弱いんだと 何も理解できないんだとという
もうすごい弱い人々 私は自分の個人的な経験もありますけど
もうどうにもならない
勉強もできない もう何もできない
もう人々ももうなかなかもう付き合ってきて
いろいろ話を聞く場合あるんですね
どんどん話を聞いてると
その人々もしっかりしてくるんです
物事を自分できちんと判断できる
物事すごく客観的に見られる
先入観はほとんどない
素晴らしい人間に変わってしまっちゃうんです
そういう証拠は結構あるんです
ですから 皆さんも もしこのこれは宗教の講演だという感じではなくて
まあ科学みたいな科学みたいなもので
科学ではないんですけどね
科学みたいなアプローチで心の説明だと思って聞いていただきたいんです
じゃあそれから話に入ります
で 心の問題ですから ですから
まず心って何ですかという問題は僕らには出てくるんです
皆様もいい加減に心というものがありますよと信じてしまっちゃったら
もうそれからは話は進めなくなっちゃうんです
ですから まず疑ってください
本当に人間に心がありますかと
証拠なかったらもう信じる必要ないんです
疑うところから知恵が生まれるんです
疑わなかったらもうそれで終了ですから
私は疑いません 信じますと
ただ それで話は終了しますね
昔 我々目で見たら 地球はもう平らで見えるでしょうに
そこで目で見えたら見えるんだから
それは平らですよと言ったら
そうですと 疑いことはないんだと思っちゃったら
それで止まったでしょうし
でもそれ疑った人々がいたんだけど
目で見えたところで平らですけど
ちょっと考えてみようではないかと
計算してみようではないかと
考えたり計算したりするときは
やっぱりあの平らではないんだと
これ丸いのではないかという考え方が生まれてきたんですね
さらに疑ってみると やっぱり確かに丸いということは出てきたんですね
そこでさらに疑ってみると
丸いのは丸いんだけど
まん丸でもないんだと
地球っていうものは出てくるでしょうに
それで それでも地球は個体できちんとあるものだと信じたんですね
そこでそれもちょっと疑ってみようと見たかったところで
地球もそれなりに大きくなったり小さくなったりするんですね
そこはまだわかってくるでしょうに
それでさらにそれ大きくなったり小さくなったりしたって
それはそのまんまだよと思っちゃって
またさらに疑ってみるとそうでもないんですね
地球もずーっと物質は変化していったりして
地球のものは出ていっちゃうし
外から宇宙から他のものが入ったりしたりしてというふうなことになってくるし
ですから疑った方がいいんです
で 宗教の世界になると
疑ったり疑問したりするのは罪なんですね
やってはいけないこと
これは人間立ち入るそこじゃないんだと
この科学の世界でも この科学者は神の世界に指を差すなと
指すんじゃなくていじるなとか話出てくるんですね
ああいうのは 僕は未だに人間は原始的だなと思っちゃうんですね
ちょっと怖いんだけど
指を差してみたって別に悪くないと思いますよ
そうすると何か新しい発見があったりはするんです
チャレンジした方がいいと思いますよ
例えばこのあの 人間というのは
やっぱり特に今問題になっているのは
この DNAいろいろいじったりして
自分好きな生命を作った方がいいんではないかと
やっぱりやっぱりそれはもう神の世界だからやってはいけないんだと
いきなり科学者はそれにまあもう釘を打ってるんですね
やっていけないんだと
そういうふうに まあ一発で釘を打つんじゃなくて
まあいろいろ自分をわがままで
もう好き勝手にいい加減でやるんでもなくて
いくらかの自分をコントロールしながら
人々のことも生命のことも考えながらもチャレンジした方がいいんじゃないかなと私は個人的には思ってるんですね
ですから このそういう知らない世界に
神の世界にチャレンジするなというのは
チャレンジしたらそれは罪ですよと
罰が当たりますよっていうのは宗教的な考え方で
科学者は持ってますけど
残念ですけど 仏教はそういう考え方を持ってないんですね
チャレンジしてみなさいと
何でも ですから 他のことにチャレンジしたったら
何かあの危ないかもしれませんだけど
まあ大体仏教のことにしたってもしても自由ですから
したってもではなくて
仏教のことだけにでもチャレンジしてみてください
そうすると皆様に何か理解できる可能性はあるんです
そういうことで まず疑ってみてください
本当に心があるかないかと
もう一つわかりやすい例を
僕はできるだけこの話をわかりやすくしようと思って頑張ってますけど
例えば人間に頭がありますかないかと聞いたら
いきなり答えなんですか
人間に頭がありますか？いきなり出てくる答えはい
ありますよと 何聞くんですか？と
馬鹿な質問するなという答えでしょ
でも違うんです 私はもし皆様方に人間に頭がありますかと聞いたところで
皆様方は知識人であるならば
僕に返って質問しなくちゃいけないんです
頭って何ですか？と なぜならば
頭という言葉にいろいろ意味があるでしょうに
例えば文章の頭という言葉あるでしょ
日本語でも同じ言葉あるんでしょうか？わかりませんけど
英語だったらありますね
ヘッドという もし私はそれを考えて聞いたならばどうなるんですか？あるいはもうその場合は何かの始まりという意味でも頭ということがあります
それからメイン 大体一番大事なメインパートという意味でもヘッドという言葉を使ったりするし
それで僕はいきなり人間に頭がありますか？と言っちゃっても
それは曖昧な質問で答えちゃったらもうもうやられてるんです
それはいと答えるだけではなくて
あんたなんでつまらない質問するんですか？そこまで言うんだから
そこまで人間はもう無知的なレベルにいるんですね
ですから 私は人間に頭があります
言ったら頭って何ですかと
ちゃんと定義しなさいと
と私にかえって質問しなくちゃいけない
そうすると私は定義をしなくちゃいけない
そこで私は定義したところで
その定義に当てはまるものはあるかないかと
自分で試してみて 答えた方がいいんです
そのやりとりなんです
ですから 我々はもう 100%もうやられっぱなしで人々に
ですから ほとんど真実を知らないままに終わってしまっちゃう人生っていうのは
だからいきなり心って何ですかと
そこで私は仏教の定義をします
で その定義からそれから話を進めます
仏教で心というものは
あの物事はなかなか明確に分別することはちょっと難しいんです
皆さんはよくお飲みになるお茶ありますね
お茶と水を明確に分けてしまうことはできますかね
これは水で これはお茶だと
とはなかなかできないんですね
分けちゃったらもうお茶でなくなっちゃうんですね
お茶っていうのはやっぱりお湯に
お茶の成分が溶けているものなんですね
ですから 明確に厳密に区別して分別して分けることは不可能なんです
ちょっと難しいんですが
分けてみた方が正しいんです
そこでお茶の場合は 水というものを別に認識することはできるんですね
お湯をお湯を別にして飲んでみたり
触ってみたり 体験したりすることはできるんです
そこでお湯にない 特色がお茶にあるんですね
それでお茶をお茶の認識できるんですね
そのシステム使うんです
ですから ちょっと科学っぽいと言ったらそういうわけなんです
宗教っぽいじゃないんです
そういうシステム使って体というと
皆様は科学的な の知識は豊富ですから
この物質の世界はよくご存知ですね
物質の世界 例えばこの建物は物質で
この世界は物質で 外を見ると見える星やらもう全部まあ一応物質で
そこはわかるんですね
そうするとこの体もこの地球から生まれたものだから物質なんですね
私たちは宇宙からどこかの星から
あるいは火星でもいいんです
土星でもいいんだけど
持ってきたもので体が作ったわけじゃないでしょ
今 私という体は全部この地球から頂いたものなんですね
ですから 体自体は物質であって
そこら辺を理解するんですね
物質が いわゆる体は物体ですと
物体といったところでもっとさらに大胆に行きます
物体であるならば この机も
このもうじゅうかく このホワイトボードも
この建物も物質なんですね
そうであったら この体も
このホワイトボードも全く同じなんです
物質ですから 私の体もこの建物も全く同じですと大胆に決めなくちゃいけない
じゃあそれで止まって考えましょう
私の体もこの机も全く同じものだと
言ったら納得いかないでしょ
机イコール私と 山イコール私と
この建物 このビルイコール私ですと私と全く同じものやと言っちゃったら
皆様ちょっと待ってくださいと
もう嘘 もう休み休み言ってくださいと言われるかもしれません
ということは 我々の実感で
このイコールイコールで言ったっても
何か違うんじゃないかなというとこあるでしょ
その違うところは心なんです
じゃあ心の認識はそういう点
そういう立場から見ると簡単なんですね
それで私はこのホワイトボードの前に立ちます
で 物質として私もこれも同じなんです
そこででも何か違う 何が違いますか？全部リストアップしてみましょう
もう残念ながら あまり私は日本語を書くのはあまりではなくて
全く書けないものだから
ちょっと書くのは難しいんですけど
皆様リストアップしてみてください
そうすると心は見つかるんです
で でも だからといって
例えば私は服を着ているんだと
これは服を着ていないんだと
それは違うんではない
それは関係ない それはバカバカらしい
なぜならば 私にも服を着なくたっても生きてられるんだから
別に これも何かで なんで服を着ていますか？体を守るためでしょ
で このボードもよく守っておきたければ
何かのカバーでカバーしておけば守れるでしょうし
ですからそれは同じなんです
こういうこと違うんです
私はこんな風に元気で立ってるんだけど
1 日 1回2回でもご飯食べなきゃどうなるんですか
ご飯食べなかったら この姿はどんどん変化して
痩せちゃって 立つこともできなくなっちゃって
消えてしまうんです このホワイトボードが全然ご飯食べない
そこら辺ちょっと違うんですね
それご飯食べるというどういうことかというと
この物体を支えるために新しい物質を入れ替える
新しい物質を入れ替えて
この構造の状態を保つ
でも これにはそれがそんなに要りません
そこに我々の差があるんですね
ご飯食べる 動物だったら餌を食べる
それで自分の姿を守るために外からものを入れたりして
それは内臓 内臓 構造にそのまま入れ替えるならば
それみんな生命であって
心を持っているんです
それにこれは心の働きです
でも心は見えません だけど心の働きなんです
そういうことで 仏教ではこの目に見える微生物も生命として考えてるんです
人間と同じ 人間だけ尊くて
他の生命はもう尊厳はないんだと
魂はないんだから 動物は殺してもいいと
とは仏教では言わないんです
なぜならば 科学的に見ると
微生物もちゃんと餌を取って生きてるし
私も別に同じことやってるだけ
取る餌違うだけで ですから同じと
そういうふうに決めちゃう
それ一つ またいろいろあるんですね
そこでこの食 食べることですか
食をいただくことからいろいろ考えましょう
そこで物を外からいただきますから
私は何を食べるべきか
何を食べてはいけないかと判断しなくちゃいけないんです
これにはそれ関係ないんです
このホワイトボードにも
それで私には何度も物を選ばなくちゃいけない
その判断する能力あるんです
それも心の働きなんです
そこで判断する方法によっては生命は違うんです
例えば 人間は目で判断する
犬は鼻で判断する コウモリは耳で判断する
コウモリとかフクロウとか
この夜行性の動物は結構耳で強烈に物事をちゃんと判断する
いわゆる人間は目で見てるんだけど
ある動物は聴覚で物事を見ているんですね
私たち同じく見えるんです
大きさやらもう全部 3次元で
その働きは心なんですね
判断する働き それから判断すると
またいろんなもの 問題が生まれる
例えば 皆様この建物を見て
この部屋を見て いろんな判断をする
この蛍光灯やらこの灯りを見て
これは明かりであって
これは天井であると これは壁であると
これはホワイトボードであると
これは自分の机である
自分の椅子であると そういうふうにいろんな判断をするでしょ
これは私であって 他の人々
他人であると判断すると
我々には心の体の中でいろんな変化が起こるんですね
いろんな変化が起こる
例えば何か見て ああひどいと気持ち悪いと思っちゃったら
体中変化を起こすんです
何か見た瞬間でいきなりそれはすごい怖いものだと判断しちゃったら
いきなり体全体変化するんです
自分が一人で夜寝ていると
そこで隣の部屋から音がする
そうすると音は判断する
その判断によって体が変化してしまっちゃうんです
あの音は泥棒だと判断しちゃったら
すごく怖くなって汗が出て変化する
あの音はお化けだと 幽霊だと判断しちゃったら
また体はそれなりの違う変化を起こしちゃう
それは心の世界なんです
ですから 人間にとってはこのいろんなことを判断することによって
いろんな悩みが生まれる
自信がつける 自信が消える
楽しくなる 悲しくなる
寂しくなる 嫌になる 苛立つ
いろんなこと生まれるんです
同じ物体であるこのホワイトボードが全然何もなく平気で
その働きは全てまとめて我々は心の働きと言うんです
それで心の証拠あるんじゃないかなと私は思います
ですから この不可思議なものではないんです
心っていうのは得体知らないものではございません
神様の世界でもありません
ものすごい具体的なものなんです
で 人間なら早く死んじゃいますけど
だいたいこの保存さえ良ければ
地震でも起こらなく 地震とか火事とかそういうものなければ
この物体とここにこのスマナサーラという物体とホワイトボードというこの物体で
2つの間で長生きは誰にできるんですかと
やっぱりホワイトボードが長生きするんです
地震やら火事やらね まあもうなくて
雨にも濡れないで置いとけば
もう 100年でも平気なんです
でもこの物体はそうじゃないんです
なぜ違いますか？心があるんだからでしょ
今 今から言えば 食べ物を食べなくちゃいけない
それに判断しなくちゃいけない
判断すると 苛立ったり
困ったり 悩んだり 喧嘩したり
仲良くしたり いろいろやらなくちゃいけない
それでどうせ喧嘩したり
悩んだり 苛立ったりすると判断が間違っちゃう
でしょ 例えば ものすごく精神的に悩み事ある人は
過食症か拒否 何て言いますか
拒食症かどっちかになっちゃうでしょ
あるいは食べる時も 体にいいものじゃなくて悪いもの
あ これはもう食ってしまっちゃうという感じで食べてしまったりするんじゃないんですか
それ 自分の健康状態悪くなるんじゃないんですか
ですから なんで私は早死になりますかというと
心があるんだからなんです
なんで人間は戦争したりするんですかね
じゃあなんで人間は幸福を感じるんですかね
それも心があるんだからなんです
ホワイトボードは全然平気でいるんだから
幸福は感じない 同時に
なんで人間は不幸を感じますかね
それまた心があるんだからなんです
そういう私というこの物体と他の物体と区別できる一切の働き
いっぱいあるんです ものすごいたくさんあるんです
それは心の仕事 そこで皆様先生
私にもう質問しないんだけど
で なんで心の仕事というんですかと
なんで心の働きというんですかと
今 心の証拠を出しましょうと喋ってるんだから
ちゃんと心の証拠を出せと言われた方がいいんだけど
で 私は心と言わないんですね
なんか心の働きと言うんですね
それには訳があるんです
人間がものはあると思ってるんです
でもものはあるわけじゃない
人間のおかしいところ
ものがあるんだと で ものがあるんじゃなくて
働きがあって 働きによってこの反応が起こすんですね
その反応によって我々はあるという判断するんです
あるわけじゃないんです
そういうちょっとすごいこのきめ細かいもうややこしいところで
僕はすごい気になってるんです
そういうところは ですから
言葉使い使う場合はすごく慎重すぎ過ぎほど慎重なんです
これは心ですよと言わない
心の働きですよと 例えばこのこっちこちらにこのホワイトボードがありますよと言うと
あるんじゃなくて このホワイトボードによってと言ったらちょっと言葉おかしいんですけど
とにかく皆様の目に何か反応を起こすんですね
その目に反応を起こすというか
心に反応を起こすんです
その反応を起こしたのを何かエネルギーが入ったんだからなんです
そこで頭の中で判断するんです
それはこの反応はホワイトボードですと
それは頭の中の働きであって
実際にホワイトボードがあるかないかはわからないんです
例えば このホワイトボードは触っても体に反応はない
見ても目には反応ないと
舐めてみても舌で反応ないというならば
ホワイトボードはない
で 皆様に空気が空気が見えますか？と聞いたら見えませんと言うでしょ
目から反応起こしませんだから
ですから 空気は見える存在ではないんです
でも体手をちょっと振ってみたら体に反応起こしちゃうんですね
それで空気があると ですから
働きはあるんだけど ものはないんです
ですから 心もないんです
心という働きがあるんです
ちょっと難しいかもしれませんんだけど
で あの これはこのものはなくて
ただただの働きだけですということは
まああの仏教の世界ではやっぱりこのこのとことん体験して
修行して 体験して分かればよろしいことで
まあ具体的に 的な例で考えましょう
ある人がここにいて すごい醜い格好で醜い形で来て
聞きにくいというか 聞きたくないという言葉で散々私に喋っちゃうんだ
そこで私はすごく苛立ちして
腹が立って その人と喧嘩すると
そこで第3番目の人が来て
なんであなたはその人と喧嘩するんです？それはその人は大変失礼だと
礼儀はもう正しくないんだと
もうすごい失礼な言葉を言うんだと
だから悪い人だと ですから
その人は悪いんだから
私はもう喧嘩しているんだと自分は弁解するんです
それで仏教から言えば
え 違いますと そちらに人がいるとあなたはわかりませんと
あなたは自分勝手に怒ってるんだと
あなたは自分勝手に喧嘩して苦しんでるんだと
それはその人のせいじゃないと仏教から言えるんですね
それはどういうことかというと
人が仮にいるとして その人が喋ると
その音を聞いて私は反応を起こしちゃうんです
私はイライラのイライラ反応を起こしちゃうんです
その人を見て 私は嫌な反応を起こしちゃうんです
そこで自分の心に起こった反応によって
自分が苦しみ味わっているだけなんです
そうじゃなくて ちょっと違う角度でそれを見ると
別に苛立ちも何もないんです
例えば映画を見ていると
楽しみながら同じ言葉が他の方向から
例えば座って映画を見ている前
スピーカーから同じ言葉が出てくると
隣から 例えば右側から同じ言葉耳に入っちゃうと怒っちゃうんですね
ぶん殴っちゃうんです
誰が悪いんです そうすると自分の心なんですね
やっぱり ですから この人がいるかないかということ
物があるかないかということではなくて
我々の体の中でありとあらゆる反応が起こす
変化が起こる そういう働き機能があるんです
で 水はずっと流れていると我々は川と言うんです
流れない場合は川と言わないんですね
湖というんです ですから
これは湖ですか 川ですかと言うためには
何か働かなかったらダメなんです
大量の水が 1箇所に止まっていると
我々は止まっていると考えると湖という
我々から流れていくんだと
海まで流れているんだと
反応を起こすと川というんです
ですから 働きは大事なんです Function
はものすごく大事なんです
物は大事じゃないんです
この物があるということは
人間のものすごい妄想概念ですごい間違いだと
例えば包丁は何ですか？と言えば
台所の使う道具なんですね
そういうものがあるならば
包丁で殺人を起こすことはできないんです
そうするともう裁判で包丁でこの人は人を刺しましたと言ったって
包丁というならば 包丁は台所でキャベツを千切りにする道具ですよと
人を殺すものじゃないんだから嘘ですよと
私は無罪ですよと言えるんですけど
でも包丁といっても 包丁はその時その時いろんな仕事をする
別にですから 包丁と言わなくてもいいんです
台所でキャベツなんか千切りにするときは包丁であって
それで何か叩いて 例えば釘でも
包丁はちょっと重いんだからね
包丁のあれ あの使うとるとこがありますね
そこからもうこうやって釘でも打つ場合は金槌の仕事をやってくれるし
料理のレシピでもちょっと空気が風が来て
もう飛んでいきそうになっちゃったら
ちょっとすぐその上に包丁を置いておくと
それはただの重りの仕事をしてくれるし
いろいろ仕事をするんですね
そこでちょっとだけ ちょっと線引いたくなっちゃったところで
包丁の背中のほうを使ってサッと線を引くと
その場合はその仕事をしてくれる
ものすごく腹が立って攻撃したいと
相手と戦いたいと思ったところで
手に握っちゃったら無垢になっちゃいます
そういうふうな働きをしている
我々に必要なその働きなんです
包丁ではないんです 包丁を必要というならば
切れなくてもいいでしょう
でも 切れないものには包丁とは言わない
ですから 大事なのは働きなんです
物ではないんです あの
何て言いますか 日本語でもことわざあると思いますけどね
例えばネズミを取ってくるならば
この土で作っている猫でもいいんですよというふうなことわざもありまして
日本でも同じこの壁に書いた餅でもお腹が満腹になればいいんじゃないかという
やっぱりそういうことわざはものすごく意味があることわざなんです
餅は壁に書いてあってもいいんです
別にそれによって我々がもし満腹するならば
自分の仕事をやってくれるんだから
実物の餅であろうが 食べられないものだったら餅ではないんです
ですから この働きということは一応覚えておいてください
今理解できなくても ですから
心というものを探すんじゃなくて
我々は心の仕事を探す
仕事を探したところで
悪い仕事をやっているならば
それはやめてもらう いい仕事をするようにすればいいでしょう
あなたにはこういうこういうこういう仕事もできるんだけど
でもこういうこういう仕事をやめて
こういうこういう仕事をしてくださいと
コントロールすればいいんです
そういうシステムはこれから徐々に説明していきます
まあ一応今日は理解してほしいのは
心というものはこのものすごくわかりにくくて逃げているものではないんです
本当は堂々と働いている具体的なものなんです
証拠あるものなんです
で 証拠は簡単に出せるんです
例えば 私は手でこの机ぶん殴る
それから皆様の誰か一人をぶん殴る
もし反応は全く同じであるならば
2つとも物体だけなんです
でも反応全く同じわけじゃないんです
人をぶん殴ったらすごい反応なんです
私はかえってぶたれるかもしれませんし
あるいは私はひどい目に遭うかもしれませんし
喧嘩になるかも いろんな結果が出るんです
机をぶん殴ったっても
別にそれで手が痛いだけで終わるかもしれませんし
その違うところは心なんです
そういうのはすぐ証拠あるんです
はい そこでこの人間 これ回してないんだけど
先生  回ってなかった  回してたんだ
あの自動的に降りてますね
人間またすごい都合のいいことをするんですね
この都合のいいことをするのはもうただ怠けていることの証拠だけなんですけど
例えば自分の怒り 嫉妬
怠けというこの醜い部分いっぱいあるんですね
この醜い部分は自分でないんだと
自分の心っていうのは清らかで
完璧で 清浄で 尊くて 永遠不滅で
魂そのものでとか そういうふうに思ってるんですね
そういうふうに思ってるんだから
このずるい人々がその通りにしゃべるんです
我々の心は 我々の霊魂は
我々の魂は もう本来は大変素晴らしいものであって
仏性そのものであってとか
魂そのものであってと
神様にも特別特設に入れてもらったものであってとか
いろいろ言葉を使ったりするんですね
あれはすごい都合のいいずるい考え方なんですね
例えば 人を愛する心は素晴らしい自分の本当の心であって
人を憎むことはそれは自分じゃないと
と思うのはちょっと甘すぎじゃないかなと
だからなかなか人間っていうのは
いくらこの宗教の話を聞いても全然直らないんですね
もう初めからもう間違ってるんだから
なんか結婚式なんかに行った時
みんなすごい行儀よく
言葉は素晴らしく敬語を使いながら
その時だけ それが本来の自分だというのはものすごい馬鹿げた話なんです
結婚式ではもうわけもわからない難しい日本語を使ったりとか
もう決まってる もうきちんとした制服着て制服というんですか
そういうセレモニアルドレスなんかいろいろ着たりしたりして
それで特別な化粧したりとか
それは本物の自分だと
そんなもう誤解ばっかりで
そうだけじゃないんです
それでうちに帰って もうだらしない服を着たりしたり
もう奥さんとまあむちゃくちゃ汚い言葉喋ったり
喧嘩したりとか 感情的になったりとか
それも自分なんです ですから
そこはもうその誤解解けてほしい
それ誤解でいたらもう全然もう将来はないんです
その将来天界に天国に生まれ変わって
あるいは成仏して そこで清らかな心でというのは冗談じゃないんです
その心を持っていっちゃったら
汚いものは全部持っていくんです
ですから せっかく天国に行ったってもひどい目にあうんで
そこでまた喧嘩やらしいと
心っていうのはやっぱり愛情があると同時に憎しみがあるんです
それは心の普通のあり方なんですね
これは好きやと思うと
あれは嫌いだということはあるんです
嫌いなものはないもの何もない場合は好きなものはないんです
それは心の働き ちょっとしたことでものすごく喜んで舞い上がる人は
同じくちょっとしたことでものすごくガクンと落ち込んでしまって悩んだりするんです
この自分の都合のいいようにはいかないんです
ですから これも心の特色
いわゆる善も悪も一つのセットになっているんです
いわゆる正と反のセットなんです
人を愛する心と人を憎む心
人に親切にしてあげる心と
人に失礼に人をいじめる心と
全部セットなんです ですから
このいいところだけ取ろうということはできないんです
世の中大体そういうことなの
例えば皆様 例えば何かパーティーをなさいましたと
どんなわけでもいいんですけど
新年会 忘年会でも誕生日会でも何でもいいんですけど
そのパーティーが大胆になればなるほど楽しいんですね
でっかくなればなるほど楽しいんです
これ パーティーが大胆になればなるほど
この これは正の部分で負の部分が何ですかね
負の部分はゴミがすごく大きくなっちゃうんです
お金がすごくたくさん出ていっちゃうんですね
それから疲れがもっと大きくなっちゃうんです
後片付けがものすごく大変になっちゃうんです
セットなんです たくさん楽しむと
その分たくさん大変な目に遭わなくちゃいけない
こんな簡単な例えば誕生日みたいに
ちょっと小さなケーキ 1本だけ買ってきて
それで家族を集めて誕生日おめでとうございますと言って
それを食べて それで終わったならば
後片付けは食べたあの皿だけで終わってしまっちゃうんです
楽しみは小さいんだけど
その分後片付けも小さいんです
大体人生っていうのはそんなもんなんです
皆様方 大胆に喜びたいと思うならば
大胆に苦しみ 苦しめなくちゃいけないということも考えなくちゃいけないんです
そこで究極的に楽しみたいと思っている人々は
この大変な苦労したケースもあるでしょう
で もう全財産取られても
命まで取られる場合がありますから
いろいろ早くもう悟って
みんなより偉くなろうではないかと偉いことを考えちゃって
結局自分の大事な命がなくなったということも事実上ある話ですから
そういうのは気をつけなさい
それが仏教の話なんです
喜びは多ければ悲しみも大きいと
そういうことなんです
ですから それは心の働きで
それからこの このわがままというところも
自分中心に考えることも
また心なんですね それから判断することから生まれるんです
自分中心に判断するんだから
やっぱりこの自分が偉いと
自分が完璧だと どの時も言わないので
それは口で 頭でも大体考えてないんです
自分がすごい偉いんだと考えてないんだけど
あるんです 心に そういう働きがあるんだからトラブル起こしちゃうんですね
例えばこの何で 何で人間関係でトラブルになりますか
何で人間はありとあらゆるこの
何て言いますか 分類主義なんですね
何かのわけで小さな枠をいっぱい作っちゃうんですね
まあ大きく考えちゃうと
国 国として 日本とかアメリカとかアジア
アフリカだとかだとか
国の枠があったりして
それで州としてまた枠があったりして
また村とか また小さくなってきて
また家族とか それと枠が小さくなればなるほど
お互いの関係強いんですね
世界と思ったら枠が大きいでしょ
あまりお互いに関係ないんですね
すごい薄い関係なんです
世界を枠をカットして小さい日本という枠を作ると
もうお互いのつながりが強いんです
日本も追い詰められた
自分が秋田県とか 自分が新潟県と言っちゃうと
これまたさらに繋がりが強くなっちゃう
それで新潟県の自分の村になっちゃったらもっと強くなっちゃうんです
もっとその枠が小さくして家族にしちゃったら
もっと強くなっちゃう
それでもっとその枠を小さくして自分にしちゃったら
ものすごい強烈な強いんです
ですから 自分に対する繋がりはすごい強いんです
本当のところはそこからスタートするんです
自分がいるんだと 尊い
偉い 大胆な自分がいるんだと
その自分のために家族がいるんだと
家族のために村があって
村のために もうそういう
まあいろいろあったりあったりとか
国があったり それから世界があったり
結局自分というところなんです
そこでなんで私の質問は
なんで我々お互いがトラブルを起こしちゃいますかというと
ちょっと頭だけ 建前だけ
国や世界やとか言うんだけど
それは嘘です 本当のところは私だ
私だということなんです
大変失礼な例でございますが
例えば政治家の方々は国民のためにという
すぐその言葉で喋るんですね
どんな国でもそうなんです
政治家の方々は国民のために
でも一人も国民のために殺した形跡はないんです
自分のためなんですね
ですから 政治家がうまくやらないということは当たり前なんです
それを怒ってはいけません
約束破るのは当たり前なんです
汚職することもものすごい当たり前なんです
政治家は先に自分のことを考える
次に自分の奥さんと子供のことを考える
次に親戚のことを考える
次に自分の党の人々のこと
すぐに自分の仕事をしてくれる公民とか
そういう人々のことを考える
選挙で負けそうだなとちょっと怖くなってくると
ほんのちょびっと国民のことも考える
暇がなかったら全然考えない
国民のこと ですから 例えば消費税上がるのはすぐ瞬時に上がりますけど
政治改革はものすごい
もうあと 40年も経つかもしれません
それは政治家が悪いんじゃなくて
それは自然なんです やってくれない
それは私は言ってはいけないことなんですけど
やけどもう外人だから
この外国人は政治喋っちゃいけないんです
政治ではなくて 僕は政治として言ってるんではなくて
この世界の普遍的な在り方として言っていることなんです
で 例えば日本の皆様方
この政治家がもう政治改革やってるんだと
みんな約束して誰もやってくれないのではないかとか
嘘つき屋とかもう腹括る必要ないんです
やってくれないのはまあごく普通なことで
なぜならば自分に一番関係ある近い人々だから
そういうことで まあたまに怖いものを知らない人々がいるならば
やります 例えばカナダだったら
まあ政治改革はとことんやってしまったという話はテレビで聞きましたけど
で すごい混乱があったりして
もう大変な危険なところいろいろあったりしたんだけど
政治家がやっぱりいきなりとにかく国民に選ばれたんだから
国民に約束したんだから
国民が大事ですよと考えちゃって
もう成功しましたということも話はありますけどね
まあそういう人々もいるし
その場合でもやっぱり自分というものは消せませんね
この自分という立場で物事をやると
どうせトラブルが起こすんです
結局は自分のためにやってるんだから
例えば結婚する それは自分のために結婚するんです
相手の人の性格に 大変素晴らしい性格であって
素晴らしい人でありますから
その人の面倒を一生見てあげますという
大変貢献的な 愛の心でやっているわけじゃないんです
この人はもうすごくなかなかいい人だから
私のものにした方がもっと自分のためになるんじゃないかという
ものすごい欲の心で結婚するんです
この人を一生捕まえておけば
自分は便利だと 安全だと
という気持ちなんですね
ですから 結婚しても喧嘩になるのは当たり前なんです
喧嘩にならなかったらおかしいんです
じゃあ具体的な話ですから
ちょっとお釈迦様の時代の例を申し上げます
でお釈迦様の時代 ある夫婦がいて
名前はナクラマーターナクラピターという名前で
このナクラ夫婦ですね
そのナクラ夫婦が仏教の拠点に名前残ってるんです
なんで名前残ってるかというと
あまりにも夫婦が仲がいいんだから
です これ珍しいでしょ？ありえない話なんです
一番仲が悪いはずなのに
それ仲がいいんだから
で記録しているんですね
その夫婦の生き方が違うんだと
お釈迦様はそれは言っているのは他の人々にもちょっと真似てみてくださいと真似たらところで
いくらか幸福になるんじゃないかということで
そこでこの夫婦はお釈迦様のところに来て
年取ったところで 前からもよく来ていて
仏教の信者さんでしたし
で悟ってもいたし で 奥さん旦那さんがお釈迦様にしゃべる場合
やっぱり奥さんのことを言うんですね
自分のことは言わない
同じく奥さんもお釈迦様しゃべると旦那のことを言うんですね
自分のことを言わない
どういうことかというと
この 旦那の方がずっと自分のために生きてるという気持ちは全くなく
やっぱりこの人の幸福のために
この人の幸せのために
幸せのために 自分がもうもう全部投げて頑張らなくちゃという
もう自分自己を捨てちゃっているんです
で 奥さんもまた同じく
やっぱりもう自分のためにやるんではなくて
もう全部もうこの人のために何から何まで 24時間で
それでも理想飛び飛び込んじゃって
理想以上の夫婦になったと
そこでお釈迦様に会ってこう言うんですね
ものすごい年取ってきたんで
会った時の話なんです
で 旦那さんがこう言うんですね
この人はすごい小さい時
向こうはすごく結婚早いですね
インドでは で まあちょっと大きくなっただけの年なんで
すごい小さい時 私のところにお嫁に来たんだと
その時からもういつでも私のことを考えて
私のためにもう本当にもう 24時間尽くしてくれるんだと
私の気持ち悪くなる言葉は一つもしゃべれないんだと
言葉はものすごく気をつけて
自分の気持ちをいつでも計算してすごい気をつけてされる
他の行動したっても いつでもなんか私のことばっかり考えてるんだと
ですから 今この 80歳ぐらい年取ったんだけど
いまだにこのきつい言葉一つも聞いたことがないんだと
一つ こういうもう素晴らしい人ですよ
って言うんですね ということは
このもし旦那がこう言ったならば
お釈迦様 私は今 80歳になったんだけど
16歳で結婚したんだけど
今まで 80歳になるまでこの人のために生きてきましたよと言っちゃったらおかしいんです
みんなそう言いたがっちゃう
それはすっごいわがままなんです
それはものすごい自己主張なんです
自分のこと言ってるんだから
私はもうずっと自分の人生
喋る時でも 仕事をする時でも
他のことをやる時でも
やっぱり自分のお嫁さんのことを考えて
もうその人のためにやってきましたというのは
自分のことでしょ そうすると奥様はあなた何言ってるんですか？とケンカになっちゃうかもしれません
でもこの人はそうじゃない
そういう軸がないんです
普通の夫婦っていうのは
大体そう言いたがっちゃうんです
私はあなたにこういうことをやってあげたんではないかと
それは親切さじゃないんです
それはわがままなんです
でも 現代の夫婦の中でもね
本当にあなたと一緒にどこか旅行に行きたかったんだけどとかね
外国にも行きたかったんですけど
できなかったとか なんとか
そういう自分にしてしてあげたくてもできなかったこととか
正直に言うと 向こう側はやっぱり喜ぶんですね
やっぱり自分のことを考えているんだと
そうじゃなくて あなたはもう毎年外国旅行連れて行ったんではないかと言っちゃったら
それは夫婦仲がいいわけじゃないんですね
よく理解してください
それで この夫婦もやっぱりこの人は言葉を喋る時でも
私のことを考えて喋るんだと
行動する時でも いつでも私の気持ちを考えてやっているんだということは
自己がないという自我がないということなんです
だからあまりにもありがたい存在だと
もったいない存在だと言われたら
奥さんも同じことを言うんですね
この旦那さんも私は何もものを知らないところ
小さい時 親に言っちゃったんだけど
その時からはもう私のことばっかり考えて
私を守ってくれたんだと
だいたいもう小さい年の女の子がお嫁に行っちゃったらひどい目に遭いますから
この大変きついもう世界ですから
女性に対しては それで私のことをよく考えて
それでもいつでも守ってくれたんだ
一言葉も私の気持ち悪くなる言葉を喋ったことはないんだと
で その夫婦これこれこれまで言うんですね
ですから 男はこう言うんですね
私は夢の中でも他の人にはいいという思ったこともないんだと
他の女性見たら あ いい綺麗な人やとかね
思ったことさえないんだと
そう思えないんですね
そこまで自分のことを尽くしてくれるんだから申し訳なく
で 女性の方も私はもう他の人を見て
ああ いい男性だなとか
そういう思ったことさえないんだと
そんな感じで 80歳まで生きてきたっていうことは
もうなんか嘘じゃないかという思うほどの不可思議なものなんです
そこで我々は何を勉強しますかというと
自己中心に生きて生きているならば
全ての苦しみは自分に入ってくる
自己中心という概念を捨ててしまえば
そこにもう極端的な幸福があるんです
本当は幸福を作ること
いわゆる究極的な喜びというか
仏教で言えば解脱でもいいし
そういうのはすごい簡単に得るもんなんです
ただ 自分というこの自己中心的な実感さえポイと捨てれば終わるもんなんです
そんな難しいことじゃないんです
滝行をやったりとかね
まあ難しい修行をする必要もないんです
毎日お祈りしたりとかね
全然要りません 真に一つただ自己中心的なこの心の働きだけポイと捨てれば
終わるもんですけど なかなかそこをうまくいかないんですね
そこで仏教の話っていうのは
このどうすれば どう考えれば
どのように世の中を見れば
この自我意識が消えていくんですかと
執着が消えるんですかという話なんです
そういう話はお釈迦様の間ずっと 四十年間の
話なんですね  四十五年間ですね
ポイントは一つ 自分がいるんだというところから
すべての苦しみ 不幸が生まれるということ
それが我々の社会でもなかなかうまくいかないのは
自分が偉いと思っているだからなんです
なんで学校で子供たちお互いに喧嘩したりいじめたりするんですかね
そのその人は自分が偉いと思っているんですね
そこで隣の学生がもう気持ち悪いやとかね
ずいぶんわがまま勝手な考え方でしょうね
もし隣に座っている学生が気持ち悪いと思っちゃったら
その思った人の心が悪いだけであって
別に気持ち悪いものが存在するわけでもないし
自分の心の回転でそれは理解しないでしょう
隣の学生は自分の心に気持ちいい反応してくれなくちゃいけないんだと
それはすごい失礼にわがままな希望なんですね
それでいじめてしまう
あまり仲がうまくいかない
会社の中でも 社会の中でも
我々お互いにトラブルを起こしちゃう
どんなトラブルもとことん原因追求していくと見つかるのは
このトラブルを作った人は自分のために世界を回ってほしいんだということを考えているんだと
世界は自分のために回れと言ってるんです
それを 話でしょ 馬鹿げた話でしょ
馬鹿げた話ですけど よくやってます
全ての生命がそれを 夫婦喧嘩も同じなんです
旦那さんがずっと遅くなってくると
奥さんが怒ると それは旦那さんが不倫しようがしなかろうが
それは関係なく 自分のために回れということなんですね
でも自分のためには回して回ってくれませんね
世の中は ですから 生きることは大変なんです
1秒でも生きるということは大変なことなんです
生きることから 人間は幸福はほとんど味わえないんです
苦しみばっかりなんです
なぜならば この心というものは自己中心だから
自分のために回れていってるんだから
なんでそれ理解しないんですかね
我々 文学 宗教 いろんなことで
それあの白乗りに乗ってるんですね
堂々と言わない 子供はキャーキャーと泣いて
お母さんあれやれ これやれとかね
お母さんにいちいちもうもうもうものすごく命令したり
もうちゃんと弁当弁当作ってくれと
弁当自分で忘れちゃったらお母さんに文句言うんですね
何でお母さんそれちゃんと入れてくれなかったんですか？と
でお母さん まあごめんなさいとか
ああだこうだ謝ったりしたりして
それで子供はものすごく甘えかしちゃって
悪く育っちゃうし で 子供は悪くなっちゃうし
子供もそれなりにものすごく母に失礼にいろいろ命令したりするし
でも子供は一度も言わないんですね
お母さん あなたは私のために動きなさいと
私の希望通りに 私の望み通りに
私の幸福に向けなさい
あなたのことはどうでもいいんですよとは言わないんですね
一旦そう言ってしまえば
問題はほとんど解決するんです
でも言わないでしょ それだけ我々は徹底的に隠すんです
学校に行ったら 幼稚園の時からもみんな仲良くしましょうとかね
ちゃんと歯を磨きましょうとか
ああだこうだとか もうご馳走
何て言いますか いただきますってちゃんとご飯食べましょうとか
そういう あの 何て言いますか
社会習慣ですか 社会に適する人間作っちゃうんです
その社会にふさわしい適する人間を作るのはいいんだけど
そこでものすごい大きな過ちを作っているんです
自分のために回るということは
ちょっと隠しておく 隠しておきます
それはいじらないでちゃんと謝りなさいと
それだけ言うんです 謝ってもあの事済むわけじゃないでしょうに
ですから我々は学校も社会も家族も問題だらけ
国も問題だらけで 世界も問題だらけで
それは永遠に続くんです
消したければ もう怖いものを知らない大胆な気持ちで自分の心を見なくちゃいけない
自分が自分だけ良ければいいと思っているものだと
人はどうでもいいと思っているんだと
考えてみて下さい 自分が自分の子供に対しても
子供は自分のために生きてきなさいと言ってるんじゃないんですか
子供を愛してるというのは
それは嘘なんです 仏教から言えば
それは愛情じゃないんです
愛じゃなくて愛情ですけどね
執着と言うんです 仏教で苦しみが生まれるんだ
捨てなさいと 自分の子供に対する愛情はと
堂々と仏教で言うんですね
そんなこと言っちゃったら
みんな仏教は嫌いな教えだ
暗い教えだと言って逃げようとしてしまうんだけど
違います 仏教こそ明るい教えなんです
なぜかというと あれは子供に対する愛情じゃないんです
子供は自分の家来にして
自分をニコニコしてくれるために
自分の不満やらそういうものを消してくれるために
自分に幸福を味わわせてくれるために頑張ってほしいんです
よくいい子に育てて いい学校に入って
いい会社に入っちゃって
いい年でちゃんと結婚して
それまた結婚も親の気持ちに行く
気持ちなんて言いますか
親にすごくこの賛成できる相手と結婚して
親を安心させなくちゃいけないんですね
そういう子こそ素晴らしいいい子だと
とんでもない嘘でしょうに
あれは親じゃなくて鬼なんですね
そこで その親と子はもうお互いに仲良くしているんだけど
やっぱりそれは本物じゃないんです
そういうものからありとあらゆる苦しみが生まれちゃうんです
本当のところは 我々は自分の大体もう旦那は愛してなくたって
もう奥さんが愛してなくても
大体人間っていうのは子供ぐらいはまあ心配したり
愛したりはするんだから
僕はまあ子供のこと言いますけど
世の中みんな憎んじゃっても
あんまり自分の子供は憎むということはもうないんだから
でもあれさえインチキなんですね
あれさえ本当の愛じゃないんです
自分のためにあれやってるんです
子供はもう大学なんかいい大学受かっちゃったら
もう親が喜ぶこと それで子供は大学に行きたくないんだと
業界専門学校とか業界入っちゃって
もう何か普通の労働の仕事したいと思っちゃったら
子供はやりたいんだから
子供の自由だったらやればいいでしょうに
やらせないでしょ これたまにいるんですね
この子供がいっぱいいるお母さんたちが
その子供がいっぱいいるお母さんたちが
このもう面倒見きれないんです
面倒見きれないんだから放っておくんです
あんたはこうこういうふうにやれ
あんたはこういうふうにやれ
そんなもういちいちもう時間ないんだから
すっごい忙しいんだから
みんな放っておくんです
そこでもう一生懸命勉強したい人には放っておいて
まあ勝手に勉強しなさいと
勉強しないで 早く中学ぐらい卒業したところで仕事をしたいと思っちゃったら
もうあの子はなんか仕事をしたがってるんですよ
それだけで置いちゃうんですね
その家族を見てください
もう日本にあんまりないかもしれませんだけど
子供たちはものすごい元気なんです
そこに本当の愛があるんです
本当の愛と言っちゃうとちょっとおかしいんだけど
そこが 執着が少ないんですね
そこでそういう母に聞けば
まあ子供のことは可愛いんだけど
いちいち面倒は見られませんと
こんな体ではもうできませんと
ただそれでそれ本当のことだから
そうすると子供たちも
やっぱり母は母で もうそんなに我々のためには動く回ることはできないんだと
ですから 自分は自分でやらなくちゃいけないんだと思ったり
それで兄弟もお互いにすごい心配する
母にしてあげられないことは
もう上の兄弟はちゃんと下の兄弟にしてあげる
小さな子供がいると まあお母さんは忙しいんだから
上の女の子なんかいるならば
ちゃんとお母さんの役をしてあげる
それであの執着的な厳密な
このあれその汚い繋がりが消えちゃうんです
そういうこともあるんですけどね
とにかくこの人間っていうのは自分のために回れと世界は
ということで生きているんです
でも事実は 見るとみんなそう思ってるんだから喧嘩なんですね
だから私はあなたは私のために動いてくださいと
私の希望通りに私言う通りに私の幸福のために動きなさいと言うでしょ
その人は違いますと あなたは私のために動きなさいと
そこで喧嘩なんです ぶつかるんですね
だから事実を考えましょう FACTS
仏教はFACTSから考えますから
私たちには何がやりやすいんですか？人と喧嘩すること
人と仲良くすること どちらの方が心に聞いてみてください
やりやすいんですか？一番やりやすいのは喧嘩することなんですね
例えば人がすっごい大きな声で喋っている
まだ止まらない 私の話みたいに喋るは喋るは止まらない
そうすると一番まず出てくる感情は何ですか？出て行け
黙りなさい うるさい そういう感情でしょ
まず出てくる そう言っちゃったら
この人はちょっとやばいと
この人はもうちょっと目上の人だからと
会社のもう上司だからという状態があったら
やっぱり黙れと言っちゃったら
まあ自分が黙されますから
ちょっと自分のまた考えちゃうんで
自分の幸福を考えてはいはい分かりました分かりましたと
もう仲良くしようと努力するんですね
あれはもう努力だけで本物の気持ちじゃないんですね
本物の気持ちはすぐぶん殴りたいという気持ちなんです
そこは真実なんです ですから
自分の心で聞けば教えてくれるんです
本当のこと で あの これからの話
これからずっと続きますけど
そういう我々は自分の心に聞かない
誰か先生に聞いてもらうとか
宗教の誰かに聞いてもらうとか
聖書に読んでもらうとか
そういうごまかし嘘をやってるんだからね
そこはなんとか直して自分の心に聞きなさいと
そこに真実があるんだと
本当の生命がそこにあるんだと
という話は まあこれから次の話にしたいと思っているんです
で 今日の話はまあ時間になりましたけど
心は何ですか？という
ですから そういう我々は物体と区別できる全ての働きは心の働きです
ですから 素晴らしいものだけではなくて
もっと大きく醜いものはいっぱい入っているんだと
ということだけを理解していただければ
まあ十分です いろいろ難しいことを申し上げましたけど
まあ分からなかったなどは
それはまあそれで構いませんですけど
まあ時間になりましたので
本当にどうもありがとうございました
はい  [終演の音楽]